so china's second largest port in the
eastern city of ningbo halted operations
on wednesday after an employee tested
positive for coronavirus the shutdown
could add more pressure to strained
global supply chains chinese ports are
still working to recover from our
typhoon in july and the shutdown of the
yantjian port in may after a coronavirus
infection the ningbo port is
particularly crucial to global trade
handling 19 million shipping containers
so far this year through july
and for more on that story let's bring
in fabian
journalist in beijing good to have you
with us fabian how serious are these new
kovit 19 outbreaks in china
that's a very interesting question
actually if you only look at the
absolute numbers then um the outbreaks
don't seem dangerous at all because
you have maybe 100 local infections on a
daily basis and 1.4 billion chinese
people living in the country but it's
the first time
since roughly a year that an infection
cluster has spread
from north to south basically
more than half of the provinces have
registered infections and just one case
is enough for the authorities to shut
down a whole port
because they have a really very strict
zero covet strategy and just in the last
days i visited one of the residential
compounds here in beijing that was also
sealed off only because of one case and
there are
roughly
24 um high-rise apartment buildings so
tens of thousands of people
cannot leave their buildings only
because of one infection so yeah it's
definitely very serious in that regard
right i mean you just mentioned beijing
zero kobe strategy while of course it is
commendable to try and curb the spread
of the virus as soon as possible it must
have an impact on the chinese economy
yeah that's a very a complex question
because last year the zero covert
strategy turned out to be very
successful also for the economy i mean
china was growing and because you had a
virus-free zone so to speak within the
country factories could work at normal
capacity you had a complete supply chain
in the country um however the pandemic
it's not a 100 meter sprint it's a
marathon and the strategy that was
successful last year um can be a burden
now because the economic costs are much
higher now you have the delta mutation
and the risk um despite a very strict
quarantine system of local inflict
sections and also
local infections that spread throughout
the whole country are much higher and
for every case you have to shut down a
factory you have to shut down a port
in may for example they had to shut down
the yentian port
near shenzhen and that was basically the
biggest incident
disrupting global supply chains that had
a bigger impact even than the incident
at the suez canal so at some point it
will become a problem however they are
trapped in this strategy not only
because they don't trust their
domestically produced vaccines also
because of the political propaganda last
year they already propagated the victory
against the virus and now that at least
that rhetoric leaves them not so much
space for an exit strategy right so the
virus is not playing ball there fabian
gretchen in beijing thank you so much
and of course we all know when china
sneezes the whole world is catching the
flu so conrad busan joining me in
frankfurt now uh what does all of this
mean for businesses and for consumers
here in europe
well monika i can tell you what it means
i went to an ikea store last week not on
business but you know to shop for stuff
and about one third of the products that
an ikea store in germany usually sells
is not available and the staff told me
that the things are either stuck on a
container ship somewhere between china
and germany or when somewhere in the
world a factory has a corona case it
often closes down immediately so it
can't deliver so we are really talking
about ripple effects in the global
supply chains here should germany try to
become more independent from all this a
majority of economists here in germany
are convinced that this is not a viable
way
you know not buying stuff from china
would make consumer prices much higher
here in germany and let's not forget
germany's economy is one of the most
interconnected worldwide
the exporters need the global supply and
delivery chains all right a lot at stake
there conrad business frankfurt thank
you so much